close
the gap between you and
god
what does that mean
it's all about identity
it's all about loving and accepting
yourself
what if exactly right now
as you are you were able to radically
love and accept yourself
just like god would
and recognize
that the will is
happening surrender to
the flow of the awakening happening
through you loving and accepting
yourself
first and foremost and then shifting
your identity from being a person
to being god
much of this channel as
there has been a very clear ascent into
metaphysical truth
finding this meta pattern
is now about simplifying spirituality
to help those that
are seeking to heal
their confusion and to understand their
true nature
so let's break this down into two parts
first is the radical love and accepting
of yourself
and the second part is shifting your
identity from personhood
to the very source of creation itself
all being one intelligence at play with
itself
god at play with itself
the two are ultimately
one but we're gonna separate them just
for those that are especially
experiencing
suffering right now or especially
experiencing
not really knowing or loving or
accepting themselves
or even if you have experienced that and
you haven't yet
popped into the very
subtle awareness of beingness
itself or popped into being the very
source of creation itself
so you have to know love and accept
yourself
as you are right now
you secreted from this planet
you came with an intention and a purpose
that very secretion
can be thought of as any one of these
incredible fractal-like expressions of
the planet
you are that massive sequoia or redwood
tree
we love our california so we will use
that as an example
when you put a noisy mind on top of the
redwood or the sequoia tree
that is constantly suffering
and constantly toiling around in
thoughts of the past or thoughts of the
future
that's where all the suffering happens
the radical loving and accepting
yourself
exactly as you are is just being right
here
in this moment and just training your
mind like the buddha taught
and so many other mystic traditions to
just
stop being noisy use the breath
as your tool to calm down the noisy mind
from the past
and from the future where all of the
anxiety and the depression
happen and just be
present right now and tap in using your
breath
into i am just simply
awake i am aware
i am conscious i exist
might that in fact be god the very fact
that i
exist might that be god and how could i
be so
arrogant
to not see myself in that same
loving way that god sees me how could i
be
so arrogant to be polluting my existence
with my noisy mind in the past and in
the future
how could i be so arrogant to not be
the very loving presence that god sees
me
okay so now you can tell that the
strategy that we use to know
love and accept yourself which this is a
main component of the teaching
of raw in the law of one
and bentino massaro has done a great job
distilling this as well
and currently mark as well in the accept
yourself 2.0
program is doing a really good job at
this radical self-acceptance
teaching
take this no love and accept yourself
paradigm use the breath
to still the noisy mind and treat those
like
clouds that arise and pass
inside of the sky in the sky is the fact
that you exist
the sky is your awareness the sky is
your very beingness your very
i am-ness and the thought clouds arise
in past some in the past
some in the future but drop
all of those drop them be by using your
breath to steal your mind
drop those and over time you'll get
better and better at not getting lured
out by those just like you'll no longer
get lured out
by the intoxicative maya
where you're trying to seek peace and
happiness in
substances and experiences and
relationships
and material possessions but instead
just like in the parable of the prodigal
son you'll hit a breaking point usually
catalyzed by suffering
and you'll get whacked hard enough to
have that catalyze your turn inward and
in that process you'll become aware
of the your very existence that the very
awareness the very beingness the very i
am-ness
itself is
already god it is already
peace it is already joy sat [ __ ] on
the existence consciousness bliss
tatvam asi you are that i
and my father are one john 10 30 the
kingdom of god is within you luke 17 21
all of what you were trying to seek
externally is
already here in a diamond around your
neck
as rumi said
so by loving accepting knowing yourself
deeply repeatedly
i know love and accept myself
i know love and accept myself
and just using the breath to relax
into the very knowing loving and
accepting yourself repeatedly
can close the gap
between you
and god
you are perpetuating your own
suffering through your own distortions
about peace and happiness externally
about not already being enough
i will only be peaceful and happy when
i get this or that
about when someone validates me
you see those distortions those lack
beliefs
are exactly what separates you from god
it's what creates the argument with god
so this very gap or this very delta this
very
difference is
simply you loving and accepting yourself
truly and knowing yourself by
watching all of your frames becoming a
better
witness a better observer to the play
that's unfolding and as you do so you'll
be able to more easily decipher
between when that thought cloud appears
about anxiety with the future
and instead what you do is you breathe
through it
i'm not that anxiety cloud about the
future
i'm not that i'm this presence i'm this
awareness i'm this beingness and then
all of a sudden the thought cloud
disappears
and you're like okay i'm back to just
awareness and beingness
and you get better and better at that
and that's basically relaxing
into the love of god that you already
are so you close this illusory gap
and you commune you unite with what you
already
are which is god's love light
and now the second part is the shift in
identity
so as you know love and accept yourself
you'll also need to shift your identity
shift your identity from being a person
a separate finite physical entity
with a bunch of separate finite physical
entities
on a finite physical planet that has
no meaning randomly orbiting a star
shift your identity from personhood
to god shift your identity
from separate personhood engaging with
other separate persons
to god because when you do that
what happens is you recognize that
i am god and we all
are god and when you do that
everything you do after that becomes
you realizing that it's god interacting
with
itself
you go back to the very source
of creation itself and see that you
are the source that made creation and
it's
all god playing with itself
so now every time you engage with
another person
you see that it's god playing with
itself
every time that there is some sort of a
catalyst
of suffering it's just reminding you to
close the gap
between the illusory separation
and the intoxication of maya
and your person identity to re-identify
yourself as god to reunite
as god every catalyst is just trying to
fix the distortion
and the more that you turn around the
more that you
unfreeze your will and choice
from the algorithms and the scripts that
we've perpetuated with our conditioning
and rather we sovereignly
turn inward and unite with this very
force of creation re-identify yourself
with the very
force of creation itself
i am the force of creation
i am source expressing itself
as god playing with itself
that's all you need to do
you will no longer see separate people
you will see everything as
god playing with itself
you will see everything as a divine
exploration
you will see this entire universe as an
appearance of infinity
it's that simple radically
know love and accept yourself
again radically know
love and accept yourself
and
relax the contracted identity
from the person to
god to the very source of creation
itself
if you do those two things radically
know love and accept yourself
see yourself as god sees you with that
same
love have the same love for yourself
that god has for you
because you are that there is no gap
it's an illusion but it's up to you
to disassociate yourself from the
contracted
energy of personhood towards
being god towards recognizing yourself
as god as source as the one infinite
creator
expressing itself in this creation
so again the two things know love and
accept yourself radically
truly
unconditionally
and the second thing shift your identity
from being a person
to being god
to being the very source of creation
itself
and see everywhere you look is
all god playing with itself
everywhere is that and that is the
eradication of malevolence
that is the eradication of suffering
you will no longer inflict malevolence
because you will truly know yourself you
will truly be a gnostic
being you will know yourself as source
as the one infinite creator expressing
itself and you
will see the one infinite creator source
god
everywhere you look playing with itself
you'll come from there rather than
coming from your person conditioning
you will come from god you will come
from
a pure place of serving your own
creation
that's as simple as we can get
spirituality
know love and accept yourself and
identify
yourself as god as source
not as the person
so shift your identity to source
to god at play with itself and radically
know love and accept this
beautiful individuated spark of infinity
that you are
you have a unique gift you have a unique
firework
a unique individuated contribution to
this civilization
to this creationary exploration
but the noisy mind toiling you around in
the past and the future
and experiencing suffering that
process is holding back this beautiful
creative spark of the infinite
that the whole civilization is pumped to
experience
especially your family your friends your
community those closest to you
in order to bring that forth to shine
that to actualize that
quiet down the mind through the breath
recognize that you're not those thought
clouds that are appearing
in the past and the future creating
suffering anxiety depression and as you
quiet your mind down repeatedly over
time
you'll recognize that you're actually
the sky of awareness of being of i
am of i exist of god you are the sky of
god
that is omnipresent
that was distracted and distorted
by the thought clouds but that has
regained its sovereignty its will
its choice its ability to recognize
that this is its own perfect
creation the knowing
the loving the accepting of the diamond
that's already around each of our necks
to really enable that individuated
firework to express
from a place of pure service to the
creation
infinite love and adoration close the
illusory gap
between you and god by recognizing that
you are not a person
you are god interacting with itself you
are the very
source of creation this is a cameo
an appearance of infinity that you
created
and when you radically know love and
accept yourself
you can properly firework outward
in pure service to your own creation
thank you i hope this brought you value
i hope that these
simplifications of spirituality will
resonate
and will heal the confused seeking
impulses
and
i'm very grateful to
be in a position of having
seeked my ass off to find
metaphysical truth and then be able to
distill it
down for people in a very
relatable way and that that is currently
the way that
the creator is asking me to express
myself
and so i am now going to be focusing on
expressing myself that way
and i love you
so much because i am you
we are the same one intelligence at play
with itself
and we are just trying to serve that one
intelligence at play with itself in its
own
awakening
and so if the video brought you value
like it
helps the algorithm subscribe to the
channel if you haven't yet leave a
comment below with where
you're at in the process and i'll aim to
get down there and reply
you can join the sim club
and we have an exclusive chat where
i jump in and help people on their
journeys
more frequently and
share the video with people that you
feel like this would resonate with and
bring value to
that's all infinite love remember
radically know love and accept yourself
and
shift your identity from personhood to
the very
source god at play with itself
ah
you